my name is Alan
you'll be great tonight yeah exactly how
did it feel for you so having a swamp
situation it's like um what's that shows
like how swap or like spouse swap where
like this switch for a second right that
game that show your girl
I was happy to be able to fill in for
Val he's been doing so well with Gabby
this whole season and you know I'm happy
that he's happy I already spoke to him a
little bit and he was he was proud of me
though that means a lot no but Gabby is
is phenomenal and it was it was amazing
I mean yeah it's a testament to her that
she was able to just jump in and and do
it with me so yeah when I'm watching you
dance I'm like who knew
that's honestly I love hearing that it's
like the best thing to hear I don't like
it's like a big surprise yeah
that's me you know but Alan's been great
yeah how are we feeling mind body and
soul right now like let's go through
that process like what's going on it's
all very medium but we're just like
pushing forward we only have you know
hopefully week by week you just have to
take it one step at a time but you know
we have so much support around here and
it's honestly like everyone it's a dream
everyone we work with and being able to
perform like this on such a platform I
wouldn't change it for the world no
matter where my mind body and soul are
which currently right now
I was going to say any injuries my
shoulder is a little like yeah because I
have like good for nothing shoulders but
um what are these terms but
um we're getting through it and I think
like I'm just getting I'm getting so
strong I'm so buff oh
yeah watch out look at my back oh you
better oh and then look at my butt
you know the Bell has to go through
every week yeah yeah so with the whole
team situation this week
did it create any sort of rivalry or
extra competition you can't score
uh happiness have we had fun and and
happiness you can't put a number on
happiness and personality apparently
apparently you can but we couldn't it
was a lot of fun you know
um I feel like our team Vinnie as the
team captain was his spirits are so high
and we we love Vinnie yeah he's he's
amazing he makes people want to just
smile and I feel like that's what our
team dance was about you know having fun
and going out there being a collective
unit and just smiling and having you
know having fun I agree I wouldn't
change anything for the world team
scream they were right they were amazing
they were amazing
but yeah we just had a little more fun
with the claps yeah we were genuinely
enjoying everyone solo we didn't want to
dance we were clapping for them yeah
yeah I did so I did see that criticism I
was deeply concerned but it's fine what
is the goal for next week where is your
mind at and are you gonna be around next
week who knows yeah
um I think we're that's going to happen
one day at a time we'll see how are you
gonna be there next week because if
you're not
you're not I know we don't yeah we
really don't we're all up in the air
hopefully he heals fast but I'll be
there for them no matter what yeah yeah
um so I get yeah I get two Pros for the
price of one
thank you guys getting paid so maybe
price it too we get paid for this
thank you thank you guys